forests are really really important for
the whole world Brazil has been working
in forests in the first issue issues
which has developed a very unique system
to monitor forests and deforestation not
only for climate change issues but asked
for by diverse conservation Brazil has
been for the last 15 years has put
together more than roughly 50 million
hectares of areas for conservation
protected areas if you combine protected
areas for biodiverse conservation and
indigenous lands alone this result alone
and are combined with the reduction of
deforestation we reduce by four or five
times the rate of the first station in
the last ten or twelve years in Brazil
these two piece of information putting
areas for under production indigenous
land or conservation units and reduce
deforestation and make at the same time
our agriculture much more productive
with the same land base is a very unique
result that I believe not because I'm
only because I'm responsible for all of
that invisible in or only because I'm
Brazilian but I believe it's an
important result for the whole world why
because it shows that if countries
government academia civil society
private sector I'm really committed we
can reach we can achieve results that
are important for the whole world on the
issue of climate change